[Music]
entropy is the gradual decline into
disorder
i'm always aware of it passing and the
toll that it's taking on all the objects
around me
[Music]
these objects need someone to make sure
that 100 years from now they're going to
be delighting people just as they are
today
i'm an antiquarian horologist
it's quite a rare title to have next to
your name
i work on objects that have a watcher
clock mechanism
[Music]
i am maybe one of two people that has a
masters in horological conservation in
this country
i'm basically a mechanic but a mechanic
from the 17th century
[Music]
i specialize in micro mechanics and i
work on machines called automata
they're made to mimic living things in
the world
human beings birds animals flowers
i think of them as the first instances
of artificial intelligence
everything is self-contained in these
mechanisms
they run usually with springs so it's
not running on batteries it's all
running from just brass and steel
[Music]
anytime i get an object that's broken
there's this innate need to bring it
back
because these objects are so old if i
need a part that i don't have which is
more often than not the case i will go
and make it myself
[Music]
it's the closest you can get to bringing
something to life
you get a silent bird the wings are
broken there's no feathers it doesn't
have eyes
i get to bring all those things back so
that it can sing again
[Music]
i feel they're a significant part of our
cultural heritage
they were made in ways that i couldn't
even do myself they were done by
candlelight they didn't have electricity
so i know they were using a foot pedal
to cut wheels
[Music]
it's an incredible amount of work and
craftsmanship just to create something
beautiful for the sake of that
people believed that these horologists
were sorcerers so in a way i guess i'm a
modern antique sorcerer
[Music]
50.
in ghana coffins can look like this
they're carved into whimsical shapes and
painted bright colors meant to represent
a person's life or occupation um
[Music]
anon and his family are at the center of
these extravagantly designed
larger-than-life coffins made in the
shape of whatever one desires
in
it started about 65 years ago with an
odd request from a chief to be buried in
a coffin shaped like a cocoa pod
from there the request kept coming in
and anan's father realized he had a
serious business on his hands
while funerals are a sad occasion in
ghana many also see them as an
opportunity to celebrate the deceased
[Music]
when an order comes in for one of their
coffins they first get the measurements
of the deceased
carve the wood into the shape of the
family's choosing
create an opening and stand it for
smoothness
it then goes to an artist for painting
once the interior is stuffed it's ready
to be delivered to the family and these
coffins are not only delivered locally
in los angeles
[Music]
denmark russia
as fernan he already has his picked out
once morning
afternoon
what is anyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
how many times do you get one of the
only people in the world doing what
you're doing yeah there's other people
that tried it but they haven't lasted my
name's art ritchie
and i'm one of the co-owners of carousel
works and i'm dan jones and i'm the
other owner of carousel works
[Music]
we're the largest manufacturer of wooden
carousels in the world
dart and i met through a third party
that we both knew
i went over to a shop one day and we
were talking and one thing led to
another and from there it just kind of
took off i was doing restoration he's
doing carvings you know we've had a
50-50 partnership for 30 years and
there's no very shoe partners just last
over three years so
you know it's not to say we haven't had
differences over the years and it's like
being married
but not that bad
we average
in different stages probably three
carousels a year
we're actually working on four right now
we have carousels all around the world
we made the cincinnati riverfront
carousel we have one in the bronx zoo we
have one the kansas city zoo the
nashville zoo the atlanta zoo the
riverbank zoo we even made the
smithsonian national zoo character
carousels will put people in the eye of
the child oh they're absolutely
beautiful
when you watch people ride a carousel
the kids are just loving to go up and
down and with these big smiles
and then ryan comes to stop can we go
again
it's fantastic
[Music]
this story takes place in london
in the neighborhood of eastlington
behind door number seven on bovary muse
where 15 people are working hard to keep
one handmade tradition alive
globes
globes globes globes
[Music]
some of the world's last handmade globes
get made under the guidance of this guy
peter bellarby
let's begin
here's our team
[Music]
there's me peter bellavey and i'm the
owner and i have a hand in all the large
globes
there's our woodworking team they make
them finish all our bases
[Music]
our globe makers they turn blank spheres
into globes
then there's leah our cartographer she
customizes all our maps
our painters they bring our globes to
life
and leo our apprentice
there's a reason we're one of the last
making globes is extremely complicated
so ready
[Music]
we make the globe
we draw positioning lines
we apply the paper to the sphere that's
the hardest part
we paint the globe
we varnish the globe
we ship the globe
and then it's done
yeah
yeah
[Music]
yeah that's it
from start to finish for a small globe
it takes a month for a large globe it'll
take six to eight months
i mean when i started i gave myself
three months and it took two years
it is crazy if i'd known how difficult
it was at the beginning i'd never have
done it
it's not logical it's not theoretical
there are no books
it's just about patience practice and
perfection
do you love it
i completely love it
we grow up with globes we see a globe we
ask our parents where are we from what
is it all about they show us and you see
this massive
expanse and you're just a tiny little
dot that's not even there it can help
you dream of things it can help you
imagine things the only thing in the
life that's a necessity is food and
water
but if i was going to surround myself
with
with things that meant something to me a
globe would be high on that list
[Music]